[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans le 7-8
loisirs merci de nous retrouver pour
votre numéro dédié à vos idées sorties
tout de suite le sommaire de ce vendredi
18 mai une coupe de france de kung fu à
guyancourt ce week end les plus jeunes
vont s'affronter jusqu'à dimanche au
gymnase des droits de l'homme plus de
300 participants sont attendus
une rencontre organisée par le club de
kung fu wushu du dragon noir de la ville
il sera question d'écologie et de
développement durable à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
l'agglomération se mobilisent en faveur
de l'environnement jusqu'au 5 juin à
voisins le bretonneux la ville organise
la semaine du développement durable à
partir du 26 mai catherine atteint
adjointe à la culture l environnement
nous en parlera et dans le cadre de
cette semaine les familles sont invitées
à participer à un rallye pédestre
rendez-vous donné par le centre
d'animation alfred de devenir la
thématique sur la piste d'alfred ce sera
notre rendez-vous junior avec mélanie
poker ce samedi 19 mai les musées se la
joue nocturne pour la nuit européenne
des musées dans le département de
nombreux établissements restent ouverts
toutes les nuits et propose des
animations spéciales
c'est le cas du musée de la villa saint
quentin en yvelines les visiteurs ont
rendez vous à 19h30 pour un show
particulier armelo brillé en charge de
la culture à saint quentin en yvelines
nous a donné plus de détails sur le
plateau du 7-8 culture cette semaine
déclic théâtre fait son show télé donc
décliné à tous et de l'improvisation à
partir des thèmes qui seront fixées par
le public et il y aura donc deux séances
une à 20h30 à 21h30
je trouve ça très intéressant de noir en
fait à quelles réflexions justement ils
peuvent nous amener avec leur humour en
particulier sur justement par exemple
évolution la télévision qu'est ce que
l'on fait de la thyroïde avant dans
notre hui quel regard et les différentes
facettes
l'utilisation de la télévision en voyage
onirique à guyancourt une exposition
vous plonge dans les abysses du sommeil
le rêve est au coeur d'une installation
conçue à partir des récits des
participants des témoignages de rêve ou
de cauchemar mis en scène
ariane allégret elle est à découvrir
jusqu'au 30 mai à la salle d'exposition
de la ville guyancourt toujours mais
côté sport cette fois ce week-end le
club de kung fu wushu du dragon noir
organise une coupe de france jeunes au
gymnase des droits de l'homme
une première qui devrait réunir plus de
300 participants catégories poussins
pupilles et benjamins
si beaucoup d'entre nous ont déjà vu des
films de bruce lee ou deux jack kitchen
tout le monde ne connaît pas réellement
cette discipline nous sommes allés la
découvrir rapidité et précision
deux qualités indispensables pour le
kung fu cet art martial chinois
considéré comme l'un des premiers arts
martiaux demande une coordination
parfaite
il ya des techniques de demain
donc ça a comporte les points les paumes
les doigts les coudes et les épaules
jusqu'à la tête après les techniques de
jambes
donc c'est tout les coups de pied les
balayages les coups de genoux les coups
de hanches
ça peut être des arrêts de circulation
sanguine
donc soit on étranglement ou alors aussi
sur des sur un bras par exemple on
pressent l'artère révélé au grand public
est rendue populaire par les films de
bruce lee le kung fu fait travailler la
souplesse l'agilité et la tonicité mais
plusieurs pratique existe une diversité
qui plaît aux adhérents on peut
pratiquer toute sa vie de 7 ans jusqu'à
90 ans
on peut passer par toute forme de
pratique aussi bien douce que plus
brutal compétitif ou non compétitive
on a beaucoup d'armes également donc d
un traditionnel on a à peu près 5
malgré une image parfois violente le
coup fourré est surtout impressionnant
un sport accessible au plus grand nombre
les plus jeunes s'affronteront lors
d'une coupe de france organisée par le
club
les 19 et 20 mai prochains saint quentin
en yvelines célèbre la biodiversité et
l'environnement une semaine consacrée à
l'écologie à voisins le bretonneux
la ville organise sa deuxième édition de
la semaine du développement durable du
26 mai au 2 juin
catherine ata adjointe à la culture et à
l'environnement est avec nous et mélanie
également qui nous parlera d'un
événement en lien avec cette semaine
bonjour à toutes les deux jours alors on
va commencer par parler de la semaine
plus généralement donc pour la deuxième
année la ville se mobilise en faveur de
l'environnement et de nombreuses
animations sont prévues et ça commence
le samedi 26 mai avec un village le
développement durable tout à fait alors
qu'est ce qu'on pourrait trouver
énormément de choses donc tout d'abord
le lieu puisque ça se fasse partie d'un
parc de la croix du bois donc la sortie
de voisins à l'envers magny les hameaux
donc un très joli parc à l'italienne
dans lequel nous concentrons donc
plusieurs stands
il va y avoir du troc de plantes en
liaison avec jardin passion partage il
va y avoir un atelier
composteurs en lien avec les services de
l'agglomération pour lesquelles les
faits davis chinois pourront faire une
pré inscription pour ensuite recevoir
pour recevoir un composteur il va y
avoir un stand de la ligue de protection
des oiseaux stands aussi des conseils de
quartier une présentation de la flotte
deux vélos de la vélostation de saint
quentin qui vient d'ouvrir également
ceux des ruches
on va voir aussi les ruches qui ont été
installés depuis depuis trois ans ça
c'est un événement permanent je dirais
nous avons aussi très important un stand
de l'alec qui va pouvoir expliquer en
fait des éco gestes et comment faire
pour bien isoler son logement est un
centre de ce qui pousse en fait qui est
une association à but écologique aussi
pour développer l'agriculture urbaine
les les dg les échos ges et ce genre de
choses donc énormément de variétés
les gens pourront se promener dans le
parc tout au long de cet après midi donc
avoir leur avis trucks aussi donc ses
vols sur exactement
donc ces produits bio ça dure du coup
toute la semaine jusqu'au 12 juin
des ateliers sont proposés chaque jour
alors ça va d'ateliers contre le
gaspillage et la création d'objets
artistiques et même fabriquer soi même
ses produits ménagers ya vraiment un
petit mot est très c'est très vaste on
commence par la fabrication de savon
ensuite il ya des ateliers cuisine comme
vous lisiez pour comment bien réutiliser
des restes pas faire de gaspillage créer
des objets artistiques et on avait pu
voir lors du dernier salon de la
sculpture une artiste plasticienne qu'il
y avait en fait les apache ou de
versailles qui avait créé des sculptures
à base de vieilles bouteilles en
plastique en fait donc ses oeuvres il y
aura un film sur ces oeuvres qui sera
exposée toute la semaine en mairie très
important aussi
il y aura des donc les produits ménagers
puisque en fait on n'est pas obligé
d'acheter la plupart des choses en grand
ça peut les faire soi même à base de
produits basiques
je pense au vinaigre blanc au
bicarbonate de soude en fait ça fait
merveille pas besoin de taper sans
l'agriculteur voilà exactement
alors on va s'intéresser également aux
conférences est-ce qu'il y en a
également sur d'autres thèmes sur la
thématique de l'eau de la lumière
horticole et de l'agriculture
périurbaine exactement donc sur l'eau
nous travaillons avec le cid ont peint
sur sur deux axes à savoir déjà comment
on peut économiser l'eau au quotidien
c'est des gestes basiques et 1 2
robin est lorsqu on se brosse les dents
installer des mousseurs sur ses robinets
installer des récupérateurs d'eau dans
son jardin pour en fait arrosées avec de
l'eau non potable genre de choses et
aussi de l'utilité des bassins rétention
sur saint quentin en yvelines et à
voisins nous avons le bassin des
graviers qui normalement on doit être
réhabilité et faire comprendre aux gens
à quoi sert ces bassins de rétention
parce que ils ont deux fonctions ou une
fonction écologique mais aussi une
fonction très pratique pour éviter fait
les inondations tout simplement
alors comment est venue l'idée de créer
cet événement où vous sentir une réelle
une réelle sensibilité de la part des
débits si noir sur ces thématiques
il ya une sensibilité certaine de davis
chinois ou de certains vices chinois sur
ce sujet mais je pense qu'on en sort
aussi un peu sur l'air du temps je pense
que on prend tous plus ou moins avec
plus ou moins de complot en conscience
voilà de la nécessité de protéger la
planète et puis d'agir au quotidien pour
préserver à la fois la biodiversité est
aussi dans la terre qu'on va léguer à
nos enfants donc c'est la consigne est
on va pas faire quelque chose morcelé
tout au long de l'année évidemment il ya
des actions long cours qui sont
entreprises sur la ville de voisins mais
était important d'avoir une semaine un
peu fort en fait qui regroupe plusieurs
activités
donc l'objectif alors je construis ce
les esprits en fait sa rencontre en fait
que chacun à son niveau à son échelle
peut agir en faveur de l'encadrement
c'est une thématique du cou qui
s'adresse également aux plus jeunes tout
à fait le mercredi après midi nous avons
des ateliers jardinage qui sont proposés
au jardin je ne ferai donc en centre
ville avec les jardiniers de la ville
qui est en fait
on a un potager partagé qui a été créé
il ya quelques années où les jardiniers
et les enfants cette plante est donc on
va remettre en culture une partie du
potager 0 planter des tomates tout ce
qu'ils avaient planté annuellement
on va faire aussi des plantations
d'agrément il y aura des ateliers aussi
en lien avec l'association ville verte
et on a également on va parler aussi
d'un rendez-vous à faire en famille qui
s'inscrit dans le cadre de cette de
cette semaine du développement durable
donc là c'est mélanie qui va nous en
parler donc il va falloir s'équiper de
basket et faire marcher ses neurones
et oui le centre alfred de vigny vous
emmène en balade au coeur de la ville de
voisins-le-bretonneux trois heures et 6
km pour un rallye pédestre sur la piste
d'alfred une grande promenade pour
partir à la découverte de tous les
petits chemins et les originalités de la
ville des épreuves et des questionnaires
vont rythmer cette balade
il faut surtout bien se mettre dans la
tête que c'est quelque chose qui fait
pour s'amuser
donc il y aura une bonne dose d'humour
qui on espère aussi beaucoup de
de temps agréable se promener observé
surtout observé parce que beaucoup de
gens lorsqu'ils sont dans la ville ont
tendance uniquement à regarder leur
quotidien et pas s'apercevoir qu'il y a
plein de petits détails
c'est une découverte avec un thème et
oui les pays participants dont se
familiariser que les animaux il va donc
falloir chercher des animaux ou des
symboles qui les représente dans la
ville les équipes vous ont concocté un
petit parcours qui débute au centre
alfred devinez qui passe notamment par
la mairie et qui revient vers le centre
les inscriptions se font par équipes
alors les équipes
histoire de dire c'est entre amis et en
famille alors pas d'inquiétude si vous
pensez être peu nombreux
une équipe des buts des deux personnes
pas de compétition mais des surprises
vous attendront à l'arrivée il faut
s'inscrire par contre c'est d'ici le
samedi 20 mais il reste encore de la
place dans ses 26 mai je sais pas ce que
j'ai dit il reste encore de la place
et c'est le samedi 2 juin la date du
rallye alors profitez-en vous entre eux
pour vous entraîner à bien d'ouvrir les
yeux merci beaucoup mais la nier
justement on leur on le rappelle la
plupart des ateliers qui ont lieu
pendant la semaine du développement
durable
vous devez vous inscrire avant le 26 mai
justement soit sur le site du centre
alfred de vigny pour
le rallye en famille soit sur le site de
la ville de voisins-le-bretonneux et
c'est là où également vous pourrez
retrouver l'ensemble de la programmation
de cette semaine merci à toutes les deux
d'avoir été avec nous sur notre plateau
on passe maintenant à notre agenda avec
une dernière date à noter c'est devenu
un moment privilégié pour faire
connaissance avec ses voisins la fête
des voisins revient pour une quinzième
édition dans toute la france renseignez
vous auprès des habitants de votre
quartier pour organiser une rencontre le
25 mai la maison des voisins à paris
vous accueille jusqu'à cette date pour
vous remettre un kit d'organisateur mais
cette ut loisirs est maintenant terminé
merci de nous avoir suivi on se retrouve
vendredi prochain pour un nouveau numéro
et d'ici là je vous souhaite un
excellent week end
[Musique]
où